se le trajo cuatro cajas de trufas de
chocolates para la fiesta cada caja
contiene seis trufas cada invitado comió
tres trufas y no hubo sobrantes la duda
es cuántos invitados asistieron a la
fiesta vamos a seleccionar la
información que nos resulta importante
para poder hacer una relación entre
ellas
veamos vamos a colocar la letra y como
nuestra incógnita que será igual al
número de invitados número
y
todos
ok y tenemos también información donde
cuatro cajas de trufas fueron llevadas
cuatro cajas y cada caja contiene seis
trufas cuatro cajas x
6 trufas cada una o seis chocolates cada
una será nuestro primer dato importante
donde nos dirá cuál es el número total
de trufas están de acuerdo
fueron cuatro cajas en total y fueron
seis trufas en cada una tendremos el
número total de trufas
ahora vamos a hacer lo siguiente también
tenemos otra relación donde cada
invitado vamos a llamarlo y cada
invitado se comió tres trufas así es que
cada invitado cada número de invitado le
colocaremos que se comió
es trufas es decir si no hubo sobrantes
significa que y el número de invitados
por tres trufas cada una será también el
total de trufas estamos de acuerdo
será el número total de trufas
de esta manera tenemos una ecuación
donde el lado izquierdo nos indica que 4
x 6 es el total de trufas que hemos
traído y también este número será igual
al número de invitados por 3 trufas que
se comió cada uno dado que no hubo
sobrantes vamos a poner la información
con cada uno de sus colores cada uno se
comió tres trufas
el número de invitados y cada caja tiene
si nosotros hacemos la multiplicación de
4 por 6 tendremos cuatro cajas con 6
trufas cada una y eso lo podemos hacer
de manera visual tendremos
una caja de 6 trufas
cuatro cajas de seis trufas cada uno
tendremos entonces el total de trufas
que se han comido todos y cada uno de
ellos vamos a manejarlos por separado si
yo tengo que 4 por 6 es el lado
izquierdo puedo hacer esa multiplicación
de hecho llámese las tablas del 4 si yo
me sé la tabla de multiplicar del 4 sabe
que 4 por 6 representa 4 veces el número
6 y tendré
+ 6
+ 6 como lo acabamos de ver aquí 6 666 y
tendremos 6
12 18 24 tendremos un total de 24 trufas
de este lado
de hecho podemos contarlas todas estas
trufas pero lo estamos manejando con la
tabla de multiplicar de este lado del
lado derecho tendré entonces que 24 será
igual al número de invitados
que se comieron 3 trufas cada una
yo puedo ver esto de la siguiente manera
tengo un número que multiplicado por 3
me dará 24 y este número también lo
puedo ver en una posición de división
donde 24 trufas que es el total que
tengo
lo dividir
entre 3 es decir si yo tomo esas 24
trufas y las agrupó en pequeños digamos
bolsitas o sobres con 3 trufas cada uno
sabré cuantos invitados fueron a la
fiesta
y de hecho podemos hacer eso tendré
un grupo de 3
dos grupos de tres
tres grupos de tres
este será otro grupo de tres van cuatro
8 tenemos ocho grupos de tres mi número
de invitados o mi cognita será igual a
ocho
ocho invitados fueron a la fiesta ocho
invitados otra manera en la que pudimos
haberlo pensado es decir oye aquí tengo
un número misterioso vamos a poner
nuestro número misterioso con rojo tengo
este número misterioso que multiplicado
por tres me dará 24 y para que nosotros
podamos llegar a ese número misterioso
podríamos pensar en los múltiplos de 3
para que entonces llegáramos con
nuestras tablas de multiplicar algún
número que multiplicado por 3 me diera
24 y para eso podemos hacer nuestra
tabla de multiplicar del 3 donde 3 por 1
es igual a 3 3 por 2 es igual a 6 3 por
3 es igual a 9 12
21 24 3 x 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
3 trufas por 8 invitados me dará el
total de 24 trufas totales